l'Ukraine une nouvelle attaque massive
russe avec des missiles et des drones
plusieurs sites énergétiques ont été
visés ce matin sur le front est
d'intense combat font toujours rage de
sources ukrainiennes des sources
ukrainiennes évoque même une offensive
imminente des forces russes on retrouve
Gulliver crack notre correspondant à
Kiev quels sont vos dernières
informations sur les régions de carquiv
les apports déjà
alors ce qui se passe à arquive et
vaporigia c'est un petit peu différent
que lorsqu'ils massives précédentes et
en comparaison avec ce qui se passe en
ce moment même sur le reste du pays à
savoir que selon les autorités locales
ce serait des missiles de type S300 qui
aurait été tirés sur harkis depuis la
Russie la région de Belgorod et sur
zapporisa depuis la partie de la région
des abrisa qui est actuellement
occupée par la Russie je vous rappelle
la capitale régionale zapporiza et
toujours contrôlé par l'Ukraine et c'est
donc cette ville et ses alentours qui
auraient été touchés par un nombre
record de ces missiles pendant la nuit
17 et de nouvelles frappes aussi ce
matin touchant essentiellement des
objets d'infrastructures critiques ça
c'est le cas pour déjà et pour harki va
donc il y a de nouvelles coupures de
courant un peu à travers le pays parce
que en plus de ces attaques avec un
nombre record de requêtes sur harkis et
zapporisa il y a eu aussi des frappes un
peu
un peu partout en Ukraine en réalité y
compris dans l'extrême ouest du pays
dans la région de ivanofanquiev merci
beaucoup Gulliver